so as I've already told you to reset the
story big news over the weekend Russian
lawyer from the Trump Tower meeting
l'Italia vessel Nets kaya who we were
told had no connection to the Kremlin no
connection to the Russian government
just a random private lawyer acting
independently she has actually admitted
that she was a Russian informant that
she is a Russian informant so my
question immediately was how is Donald
Trump going to react how will he explain
this one and Trump did not disappoint
the explanation is so absurd that it's
difficult to even explain it to you so
I'm going to be playing the clip which
is one that took place right after the
news breaks Trump had another one of
these bizarre campaign style rallies
really really weird and to make it even
more unusual Trump showed up with a
bright red face unclear if it was a
sunburn or anxiety just bright bright
red almost as red as the make America
great again hats that you'll see in the
background if you're watching the clip
with us Trump's explanation in short is
that Natalia vessel Nets kaya isn't a
real Russian spy but Putin realized that
Trump was crushing Russia so badly that
he directed Natalya vessel Nets kaya to
say she's a Russian spy in order to make
Trump look bad and of course the
insanity of this if that is that if
Putin directed vessel Nets kaya to say X
Y or Z then that's actually Putin and
vessel that's kaya working together so
it's sort of like is when you say is it
true that this statement is false like
either way it doesn't really make any
sense here's the clip of a red-faced
Donald Trump with his hypothesis I
guarantee you I'm tougher on Russia
nobody ever thought in fact do you have
you heard about the lawyer for a year a
woman lawyer she was like oh I know
nothing no no now all of a sudden she
supposedly is involved with government
you know why if she did that because
Putin and the group said you know this
Trump is killing us what did you say
that you're involved with government so
that we can go and
make their life in the United States
even more chaotic look at what's
happened look at how these politicians
have fallen for this junk Russian
collusion give me a break this is just
the best right she's not actually
working with Russian government it's
actually just that Vladimir Putin told
her what to say which of course is a way
of being in touch with Russian
government
uh III I'm almost flabbergasted by this
and of course Trump ignores the email
evidence which I mentioned earlier which
also points to her being connected to
the Russian government for years so I
wanted to fend Donald Trump here just in
a tiny little way he's completely
clueless about most things we shouldn't
take anything he says seriously I had
forgotten about the blind submission of
the committed Trumpets to the wacky
stuff that Trump says so it's
interesting to watch them not along and
and they don't even really know what
Trump is talking about but to provide
full deference to Trump it is the type
of thing that someone like Vladimir
Putin might do right to say that someone
that was in touch with the Trump
campaign is actually a Russian informant
merely to sow chaos like it's not
actually crazy to think Putin would do
that but that would then mean that they
are working with the Russian government
so it actually goes completely against
what Donald Trump's overall narrative is
and it also would ignore the fact that
we have email evidence that Natalia
vessel Mnet's kaya has been working with
the Kremlin for a very very long time so
just amazing because Trump's defense is
proof of what he's trying to disprove by
issuing that defense truly amazing times
that we live in send me your thoughts
about this you can also discuss it on
our subreddit at david pakman.com slash
re d di t this episode of the show is
made possible in part by zipper that's
ZPE
our zipper is designing a global
decentralized peer-to-peer alliance
through which companies can provide
secure global and diversified investment
portfolios to minimize
risk zippers initial coin offering for
their new cryptocurrency starts April
16th zippers goal is to use smart
contract technology to provide a
revolutionary method of funding
transactions between borrowers and
lenders worldwide and one of the best
potential benefits would be zippers
ability to allow people with no credit
to borrow currency through alternative
forms of verifying creditworthiness on
the zipper blockchain if you're watching
this on youtube look in the description
for a link to their website and links to
information about their airdrop and
bounty program this is not financial
advice and of course everyone should do
their own research before spending money
anywhere